all right so in this quick video we're
going to go over the basic differences
between haploid cells and diploid cells
well before we get into haploid and
diploid we kind of have to have to put
down some ground rules as far as some
terminology so let's look at what are
called somatic cells and like it says
somatic cells are defined as body cells
cells of your body non-sex cells so
examples of cells of your body skin
cells brain cells nerve muscle white
blood cells red blood cells and so these
are what we mean by somatic cells what
we're going to do is we're going to zoom
in to this woman's shoulder right here
we're going to zoom out in and take a
look at skin cells as an example let's
go ahead and do that right now
and so when we zoom on in we can see a
layer of skin well you know let's zoom
on in even closer let's zoom her in at
one particular cell one particular skin
cell and so now we're looking at one
particular skin cell but you know what
let's zoom on in even further I just
highlighted a nucleus of a skin cell
let's zoom on into that nucleus and
let's see what's inside the nucleus and
when we look inside of the nucleus of
cells whether it's a nerve cell a skin
cell a brain cell when we look inside
the nucleus we find chromosomes and
that's what these stained rainbow shaped
structures are these are chromosomes
now when you arrange chromosomes into a
into an organized picture you have
what's called a karyotype now we're
getting into what's a diploid cell
notice how these chromosomes are
arranged there's two chromosome number
ones two chromosome threes and two
chromosome tens and two chromosome 18
diploid cells are what the word diploid
means is that they are cells where their
chromosomes are paired notice how
there's two chromosome six is the reason
there's two chromosome six is we inherit
one from each parent the reason there's
two chromosome fours we inherit one
chromosome four from our mother one crow
for from our father so somatic body
cells are also diploid diploid means
there that they have paired chromosomes
and in humans in humans there are a
total of 23 pairs of chromosomes for a
total of 46 chromosomes 23 pairs adds up
to 46 total chromosomes diploid cells
are also created by the cellular
division process known as mitosis if we
just really briefly examine the stages
of mitosis with this picture well here
we have the picture before mitosis the
stage before mitosis called interphase
and then the cells begin to go through
mitosis prophase and now all the X
shaped chromosomes are in the middle of
the picture that's metaphase and now the
red lines are being pulled apart that is
symbolic of anaphase and notice how in
telophase hear the round nuclei are
beginning to reform and then finally in
cytokinesis the cell splits into two so
that's a little summary of what diploid
cells are what about the other one what
about the other topic of this video
haploid cells
well again before we go into haploid
cells we need to examine some other
terms first we need to examine what are
called gametes gametes by definition are
what we call sex cells now we're going
to look at a and a woman in this example
but keep in mind that men also have sex
cells
so in our picture here we have a woman's
reproductive system and what we're going
to do is we're going to focus on her
ovaries in just a moment so gametes
sperm cells and egg cells but let's zoom
on in we're going to zoom on in in this
example two again two female gametes but
men we also have gametes our sperm cells
are housed inside of our testes we're
going to examine let's zoom on in to a
female ovary right now and when we exam
and when we zoom on in to a female ovary
we see a bunch of cells a bunch of of
egg cells inside the ovaries well you
know let's zoom on into one single egg
cell and so here we have one single egg
cell and just like the last time there
is a nucleus to that egg cell let's zoom
on in and take a look at the nucleus of
the egg cell so so far everything pretty
much looks the same inside of the
nucleus of an egg cell also inside the
nucleus of a sperm cell but inside the
nucleus of an egg so we have a bunch of
chromosomes but watch this here's the
difference when the chromosomes are
arranged from biggest to smallest
chromosome number one is biggest number
two is a little smaller number three is
a little smaller I hope you see the
difference now we're coming to what
haploid cells are haploid cells are
cells such as sperm and egg haploid
cells are gametes haploid cells are
cells with a single chromosome there's
only one chromosome number one there's
only one chromosome 15 there's only one
chromosome 17 so I hope you see the
difference the chromosomes are not
paired as they were in the previous
example
haploid cells if we look at humans
humans have a haploid chromosome number
of 23 that means in a female egg cell
there's only 23 chromosomes in if in a
male sperm cell there's only 23
chromosomes remember that's kind of the
that's kind of different from what we
said a moment ago if cells are diploid
in humans if they're diploid they're
going to have a total of 46 chromosomes
but cells that are haploid only have
half of that amount 23 chromosomes and
so these cells are created by meiosis at
the cellular division process known as
meiosis we look at this picture here
here we're in as we go through the
stages a one cell begins to pull apart
and eventually form two cells but that's
not the end of meiosis meiosis has a
second round of division the two cells
then go through a second division
process and ultimately become four cells
so that's what you see forming here is
those of there will soon be four cells
so that's a little compare and contrast
I hope that's helpful
finally when we close out this video
let's put the karyotypes
to karyotypes of a diploid cell on the
left and a haploid cell on the right and
just put up some of the main differences
between the two so here is just a nice
picture summary of the differences
between diploid cells on the left and
haploid cells on the right I hope this
video was helpful go ahead and pause the
video if you want to examine this
picture in a little more detail